Lady Gaga following Joaquin Phoenix's
footsteps literally this was an
absolutely amazing experience check out
the pop star filming scenes for the
upcoming Joker sequel shooting on the
same iconic staircase from the first
film just outside Manhattan's City Hall
in New York City
[Music]
Joaquin was there too jumping into
action as the Joker for a quick two-step
I'm just happy to be here on the
presence of such incredible artists
along with her groovy dance moves Gaga
looked the part as Harley Quinn rocking
a black and white diamond pattern top
and some black leggings I feel so
blessed that I I get sent such beautiful
things to wear and of course the classic
villain look wouldn't be complete
without the smudged eyeliner and
lipstick we are ready and so excited so
excited fans first got a sneak peek of
Gaga's Harley Quinn back in February
when director Todd Phillips shared this
pic on Instagram I just feel really
blessed that I get to make what I love
Gaga's in good company as Gotham's Cupid
of crime famously played by Margot
Robbie in The Suicide Squad films
something tells me a whole lot of people
are about to die
and voiced by Kelly Cuoco in the
Animated Series there's only one thing
stopping us from being Front Page News
no one's trying to stop us Gaga's take
won't hit theaters until October 2024
but we can't wait to see what kind of
spin she puts on the clown Prince's
sidekick
she's known for committing to her
characters Patricia how come I've never
seen you before
[Applause]
you weren't looking hard enough Patricia
rajyani is somebody that was you know
notorious in Italy and now is much more
well known around the world for this
role but there was a way to tell this
story where it was about a woman using
her body and and manipulation to get
what she wanted a woman that used greed
a woman that gave herself into Scandal
and murders for money but when I read
about her and I did research about her I
realized that inside of Patricia rojiani
was the story of many women Joaquin also
delves deep for his Transformations
Joker included I thought that it was
going to be challenging for me as an
actor I thought it was going to be
challenging for the audience and that's
exciting to me you know I
and they always look for characters that
aren't easy to to Define and they're
surprising in what in in many ways and
so that's what this was I mean I I kind
of you hear Joker and I think anybody
has their kind of idea of what they
think the film will be
um but I think Todd and Scott Silver
Script really win ways that I couldn't
couldn't have expected
um there's only just super interesting
about it really
foreign